foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Joe dumar's Hall of Famer he's got a new
title sounds really important the NBA
Executive Vice President of basketball
operations all right Joe what exactly
does that mean
I don't know it sounds important though
it does sound important Dan
um a little bit of everything then a
little bit of everything just just
overseeing the game uh put rule changes
things are happening on the court things
that are happening with teams uh you
just kind of deal with everything that
kind of comes in on your desk on a daily
basis
what's the one rule change that we need
to keep an eye on this season
there's uh something called a transition
take file where guys were just grabbing
the guys in the middle of the fast break
and just stopping the fast break and
just grabbing the guys and so
1700 of those plays last year wow over
the course of the NBA season 1700 where
the fast breaks were just stop there and
so
you know like that's a bad luck it's not
the spirit of the game so we take that
out and you know even if even even if
you have
200 of them this year and you know
that's 1500 more fast breaks that you're
gonna see so but how do you take it out
of the game Joe
so you take it out by you you you give a
free throw in the ball out of bounds
like you reward the offensive team when
they do that now and so what I've seen
like the first couple of games guys
do a reflex then is to do it like
they've been and you see guys stop and
the fast break keeps going you go okay
yeah I think the rule is working do you
send a video around do you have to
everybody has a chance to understand
exactly what you're talking about
you're exactly right you're exactly
right you send video around you show
them like look and here's what happens
to that like then when you put a rule
like this in what ends up happening so
we are at the coaches meeting I don't
know a couple of months ago and we're
talking about this and the first thing
Doc River says is okay I just got to
teach my guys how to file in the open
court without making it look obvious so
what we say is yeah just tell the guys
to like go for a steal right like you
you have to legitimately go for a steal
like you're gonna get the ball and if
you foul okay it's just a normal file so
that's what kind of happens in
situations but you're right about the
video you send video around and that's
how you Hammer home the point what is
traveling now
laughs
that's a great question I don't know
it's uh it should be more than two Joe
Joe you're supposed to know
well it should be Hey Hey Dad I know
what it should be it should be no more
than two steps is what I would say
that's my official answer because Jordan
got away with it but that was Jordan now
everybody it you know these step backs
and take a couple of hops and you know
that kind of stuff remember when
carrying the ball was a turnover Joe I I
I I do remember that I I do remember I
remember when three steps was it was was
traveling and carrying the ball was
called so I then you and I are the same
error so we we saw some different things
but what happens when they go we're not
going to call Karen was it John Stockton
or Allen Iverson
who may have started this
I I never thought about that
um damn you're right uh you know what
you may be right about that I I don't
know but I do know that it's a point of
emphasis that's that's for sure like
internally it's a point of emphasis
about like look we have to enforce these
rules we cannot continue to allow this
to get further and further away from us
and that's that's the real answer then
it's like internally yeah it's like hey
look we got to start enforcing this
because you know you see it like if you
have eyes you see what's happening you
go come on like like we can't allow that
to continue to go on he's Joe dumar's
Hall of Famer won uh two championships
with the Pistons now the NBA Executive
Vice President of basketball operations
how did you survive where with Jordan
like Michael Jordan it seems like he
likes you can't say the same about some
of your former teammates there so why is
it Mike likes you and may not like
Isaiah or Bill Lane beer or Matt Mahorn
or any of those guys
so I'll pass on why he doesn't like them
or whatever but I will say this
um I you know that he and I matched up
against each other for 14 straight years
um in those 14 years never once
that he tried to trash talk me and never
once did I try to trash talk him it was
toe-to-toe nose to nose for 14 straight
years and we never
said a negative word to each other on
the court I respected him those years
that we beat them Dan
he'd walk over every single time shake
my hand and go good luck in the finals
man and you know I could see he was
devastated with the loss we beat them
they beat us
and I stopped as we were walking off the
court and shook his hand and said good
luck in the finals so I think it's just
mutual respect it's it's like I never
tried to trash talk him he never did
that with me and so we ended up having a
real real mutual respect for each other
did you want him to trash talk you just
a little bit no
he didn't need you like he that he was
that good like like just you know just
on a different level man okay what goes
through your mind though Joe when what's
The Scouting Report of Jordan what did
you try to get Jordan to do
um
try to
he doesn't drive left as much as
possible try to
uh maybe stripping before he gets up
airborne
um The Scouting Report I don't know I
didn't put a whole lot into Skyrim Force
because it wasn't like he was going to
come out and do the same thing like it
like I said I and he's just a different
level
um
and I uh listen let me I'll say this to
you Dan
there were Knights that on the court
that he would he would do something so
incredible and my thing was to never
show an emotion one way or the other
when he did something great or not
but I can tell you many of nights I ran
back down to court after he's done
something incredible and internally I'm
saying
are you effing kidding me I'm like in my
mind I'm like running like stoic nothing
on my face but in my mind I'm saying
there's no damn way that guy just did
that bad so uh no no incredible and I
always gave him that respect I always
always showed him tremendous respect he
showed me respect and so it was Mutual
on both sides
how many times were you like you got
Dennis Rodman you got like you got the
original you know yeah
um you didn't get you know the
the different Dennis Rodman there and I
try to tell people how
incredibly athletic Dennis was and and
and boundless amounts of energy and you
could put him on worthy or put him on
bird and and he didn't care about
scoring like they don't make players
Like That Anymore Joe
he was one of one he was one of one dad
then he's the only guy I know truly that
I I can say personally truly that I feel
could guard one through five because
there are 90 guarded magic when I wasn't
guarding magic that was nice he's
guarded Mike
then he got burned all the small
forwards then he would guard Mikhail
I've seen him guard Elijah this guy I
saw him guard every single position at
an elite level
so I mean like he was one of one man
like the most freakiest different
athlete that I've ever played with
but you didn't have much off the court
with Dennis back with the bad boys
we have different Lifestyles we had
different styles wait but he wasn't like
he was with the bulls uh you're right
about that you're right about that he
wasn't but but he he was I you know he
was he was still different uh different
Lifestyles the crowds he hung out with I
didn't hang out with but you're right
then to make that point that he he was a
different player uh in person in Chicago
than he was in Detroit did your family
have a problem with you being labeled a
bad boy just because it's guilt by
association you didn't play like a bad
boy you didn't act like a bad boy
so no they didn't you know why then and
you would know this
I never tried to act like that even in
all my years plan I've never tried to
present myself as I'm a bad boy like I
played hard went at it hard no she knows
what guys physical but I never tried to
like create this Persona that hey I'm
about I've always marched my own beat
I've been comfortable in my own skin I I
don't give in to peer pressure that I
have to act a certain way so I never and
you around and so you know like I never
acted like that so it you know my family
knew that like look I'm I'm gonna be me
and peer pressure doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't phase me how would the Pistons
have reacted to what happened with the
Golden State Warriors with Draymond
Green and Jordan Poole
do you mean how did we were yet
yeah so when Isaiah hits Lane beer how
did you guys react
hey break that up fellas hey but hey
break that up fella stop man you know I
mean like look how often did it happen
though where punches were were landed
not thrown but punches
uh let's say today that it it when you
saw that with Draymond and stuff like
like it shocked everybody and and
because people don't normally see it
then and so and it doesn't happen today
it just doesn't happen in today's NBA no
one really throws punches nobody
definitely don't land punches so I think
that's why it was such a big story with
our teams you know it's a different era
man and so I can I this is what I've
said like people people were trying to
say damn people were trying to say ah
that happens all the time I like when
what are you talking about like in the
90s and that model it doesn't happen
anything all the time now but in you
know with my teams it was a regular
occurrence man like you know that was
scuffles and guys Toe to Toe and they
throw a blow or whatever it was a lot
more than than it is now and I really do
believe that's why people reacted the
way they did now because you just don't
see it yeah I agree you hear about it
you know you hear about scuffles yeah
you're right uh give me your Larry Bird
Story
I I
really haven't you know I never guarded
him I saw him talking to Dennis but I
don't know what the you know Dennis is
saying something to him he's saying
something to Dennis I but I will say
this though someone asked me the other
day they said it's the toughest Arena
you had to play in and I said uh Garden
Boston
and so why because of the you know the
air conditioning they're turning on the
winter and they turn the heat on during
the summer I said yeah all of that I
said but please let's not forget how
incredible
bird and the silky sword in their Prime
I say they were almost impossible to go
in there and be
and they said why I said because you
could not make a mistake with them if
you turn your head or you don't rotate
right on time or whatever it was those
guys made you play and it was him like
he was like he was a savant on the court
like just a savant like two plays ahead
on everything and so
um I was just talking about this uh
maybe three or four days ago how hard it
was to go into Boston and be the team
when bird is in his prime
and then you had the inbounds pass that
bird steals that
that goes back to my Savant uh uh
statement like just knowing whether it
be seeing what's happening and
anticipating and boom he jumps right in
and steals the ball does does any of
this like if you see bird or Jordan like
do you do you guys talk you know War
Stories
not really just just how are you what's
been going on man how are things going
we don't really get into the War Stories
I know grudges you don't hold do you
hold a grudge against anybody no I I you
know I I wasn't that guy man I wasn't
that I wasn't that dude that was in beef
with guys like I saw I was in LA and I
ran into uh Scottie Pippen and man we
laughed and hugged and had a great talk
and you know I I like I I got along with
guys man I got along without competed
hard against them went Toe to Toe nose
to nose with guys but I you know no
grudges man I you know Life Is Life Is
Life is good I agree what's the coolest
thing in your office there
I don't know I got this picture can you
see the pic no you can't see the
pictures behind me but I got a picture
when I got here is like hey you know we
can put any pictures you want up in your
office and what I put up was ironically
was I said I want a wilt
and Bill Russell picture and said really
most people got murdered I said no I
want to pay homage to to some of these
like like Legends like real giants so I
have a I have a picture of I have two
pictures then you'll appreciate this I
got Wilt and uh Russell
and then I have a picture
I said I want a picture of another guy
in my office and they said who I said
Gus Williams they were like some young
guy was like who is that I said Son you
got a Google man he's like who is that I
said dude you got to Google this guy and
he's like what do you mean Jordan I was
like this was one of my favorite players
when I was in high school so I got a
picture of Gus Williams in my office
that's cool that's cool yeah are you the
best basketball player at the NBA office
I used to be
I think so I I don't know I don't know
if there's anybody else in here I'm
looking around I don't I don't I I think
I might still hold that title yeah well
that's good so Adam Silver is uh
how's his jumper
I don't know I've not seen him shoot a
jumper yet I have not seen him when's
the last time you shot a basketball
man what a great question
well I don't know it had to be a few
years ago but
I said this and I say this to people and
they and they find it hard to believe
so my last game we're playing in Atlanta
Grant Hill is sitting next to me in the
locker room
I said Gee after this game I am done he
said I know you're returned I said no no
that's not what I mean he's what you
mean I said
we're getting dressed getting ready for
the game I said I will never play in
another basketball game he said you're
never gonna play in another basketball
he said not pick up enough nope ever
then when I left the court that that
night I've never played again
Patrick Ewing told me the same thing
that he he said his last game that's hit
I have no interest in playing basketball
ever again
uh absolutely and you know who else told
me that they did it for a while too was
beyond board work told me that when he
retired when he first retired
he had no interest in ever picking up a
racket again and so I I just know there
are some of us who are like that like
it's done it's over I'm not trying to
relive like all the Glory Days like you
know what I mean like I compartmentalize
it I put it in a box I set it on the
counter and go man it was great but I
I'm done you know could you take Jordan
right now one on one no no no no no no
no no
no
no you're sure yeah I'm positive of this
I'm really positive
because you don't want Mike to hear that
Joe Dumar said he thinks that no no
you might might can have the 59 year old
title it's him he's got it he's got it
um hey congrats on the uh the job there
and thanks for joining us always great
to talk thanks Dad I appreciate you man
thanks brother Joe Dumar is Hall of
Famer won two titles with the Pistons he
was uh the finals MVP in 1989.